I know we talk about different phases of parenting and especially how hard like
the little years are
but there's something so rewarding
about when your kids get to an age where you can like
watch them thrive in an activity that they are talented in
we've tried a lot of activities as the kids were little
you know seeing what sticks
and we're finally at an age where each kid has found something that really
really like
they feel confident in
they love doing
and they're like
naturally talented at
and this is why I love like
the one week camp thing
it's inconvenient timing wise
but you get to try so many different types of activities
so for example
my daughter last year did a theater camp
and now she is like
super into Broadway
super into musicals
starting to do theater in the fall
and my son has really taken to skateboarding and skateboards with his dad
and we go to the skate park as a family
and I just love this phase of parenting and getting to see your kids like
become their own people
and although we look at activities as things that enhance our life
not define our life
it is really cool to watch them grow in their confidence and their interests